[Musique]
bonjour aujourd'hui on va parler de mon
coup de coeur il s'agit d'un film pas
très très connu qui est sorti en 2007 et
qui s'appelle héros qui est réalisé et
écrit par Bruno merle c'est histoire
d'un chauffeur de salle qui s'appelle
Pierre Fauré et qui est joué par Michael
Youn qui est ici dans un rôle très
dramatique on n'a pas du tout l'habitude
de le voir comme ça donc ce chauffeur de
salle qui s'appelait Pierre Fauré il est
très rigolo tout le monde l'adore mais
il aimerait être pris au sérieux il voit
qu'on ne prend pas au sérieux et donc
qu'est-ce qui va faire il va un peu
péter péter un câble et il va kidnapper
un des chanteurs les plus connus qui
s'appelle Clovis Costa qui est joué par
Patrick Chesnais voilà votre viscosta
c'est un petit peu l'équivalent de
Johnny Hallyday par exemple et il va le
kidnapper les policiers vont lui
demander quels sont ses revendications
et Pierre Fauré répond qu'il va être
pris au sérieux donc ce film il est très
intéressant sur deux choses déjà c'est
le premier film de de réalisateur Bruno
Bruno Merle et vraiment la réalisation
et c'est vraiment des partis pris quoi
on nous donne pas toutes les clés il
faut s'accrocher pour pour comprendre on
est vraiment plongé dans une ambiance
hyper intimiste hyper cérébrale dans un
appart quasiment vidé parce que c'est un
huis clos quasiment tout film se passe
dans l'appartement de pierre-forêt ou il
a pris en otage du coup ce chanteur et
aussi ce qui est hyper intéressant dans
ce film c'est du coup la prestation de
Mickey et unique qui est vraiment
impressionnante en 2007 il sort quand
même de alors il y a pas eu encore fatal
il sort de La Beuze il sort du Morning
life donc vraiment en fait c'est
clairement ce personnage hein les
cailloux c'est carrément pierre forêt
quelqu'un qui fait rire qui fait bien
rire et que jamais notre vie on aurait
pris au sérieux mais dans ce film
vraiment on on le prend complètement au
sérieux c'est assez bluffant Patrick
Chenet aussi est très très bon et voilà
je peux que vous conseiller de devoir ce
film c'est vraiment une très bonne
surprise surtout pour pour sa fin et
pour et pour son message au final
[Musique]